One of the most exciting AI apps for
developers in 2026 is Claude. No, not
that Claude, but Claudebot, a free and
open- source project that's not just
another lame chatbot, but a tool that
takes action in the real world 24 hours
a day, 7 days per week without smoke
breaks. And it does this while
remembering everything and will hit you
up on Telegram or WhatsApp as it
automates your entire life. Over the
last few weeks, everybody's been going
crazy over it. It's racked up over
65,000 GitHub stars in record time and
caused Mac Mini sales to go through the
roof, selling out everywhere. In today's
video, we'll take a hands-on look at
everything it can do. But its popularity
has already created some problems.
Earlier this week, Anthropic, a company
that believes open- source AI is too
dangerous for the common man, woke up
and chose violence. Claudebot sounded
too similar to their beloved Claude, so
they threatened to break the developers
knees with a lead pipe if they don't
change the name. So now Claudebot is
officially called Maltbot. Actually, no.
Wait a minute. Maltbot. That name sucks.
Today, they changed the name once again
to its final form, OpenClaw. The same
dangerous AI assistant with a new
lobster identity. It is January 30th,
2026. And you're watching the code
report. OpenClaw was created by Peter
Steinberger, the founder of the
developer tools company PSDFKit, aka
Nutrient. But just look at this dude's
unhinged GitHub profile. It's less of a
resume and more of a heat map of pure
uninterrupted software obsession. What's
crazy is that this guy retired and then
came back for an encore by giving us
Moltbot for free, a tool written in
Typescript that wraps Claude and GPT5 to
stay alive 24/7. It can manage your
calendar, clean up your email, run
scripts, find out how much money you're
losing in the stock market and deploy
broken code with absolute confidence.
And best of all, it can do all of this
from your own tiny self-hosted VPS, a
Raspberry Pi, or even a Mac Mini if you
really want to overdo it. There's no
reason to pay another random startup $29
per month for the privilege. But to
understand its full power, let's put it
to work right now. The first step is to
install it, which can be done with a
single command on any system, although
Linux would be the preferred route. Once
installed, you'll have access to the
clawbot or moltbot command or the open
claw command if you live in the present.
And the first thing you'll want to do is
go through onboarding. It is going to
request that you read the security doc
about all the risks involved, but I like
to live dangerously. So, let's move
right on to the next step by hooking up
an AI model provider. You can use
anything you want here, but I'm going to
go ahead and drop in my Anthropic API
key. The Anthropic API does cost money,
but you could easily use a free open-
source model here as well. Now that
that's done, the second major component
is hooking up some kind of messenger app
like Telegram, Slack, WhatsApp, Discord,
etc. I'm going to go with Telegram,
which is really easy to set up. Just
open up your Telegram Messenger and
start a chat with the bot father. It'll
have you select a name for your bot and
then eventually give you an access
token, which is like a password that you
want to keep safe. Go ahead and give the
token to Moltbot. Then the next thing
it'll ask you for is to configure some
skills. It has a bunch of built-in
skills or you can bring your own. And
there's even a thing called MoltHub with
a bunch of other pre-built skills
depending on what you want this thing to
do. And then finally, it'll ask you
about hooks. Hooks allow you to tap into
different life cycle events that happen
as this tool runs, which is really
useful if you want it to keep memories
about things that happen in previous
sessions or trigger follow-up
automations when something important
happens. That takes care of the initial
setup, which then brings up this gateway
dashboard where you can manage
everything. It has an interface for
basic chat along with tons of config
settings to customize basically
everything. That's cool and all, but our
goal is to use Mulbot through Telegram.
And to do that, we need to go into
Telegram and send a message to the bot
we created with the bot father earlier.
You'll notice initially it says access
not configured. And we'll respond with
this pairing code. What we have to do is
take that pairing code, go into the
terminal, and run this command. And now
we're good to go. Now we can start
sending messages and it will respond
with Anthropics Claude as the backend AI
model. And now we can start refining its
personality by simply chatting with it.
I'll go ahead and name it assistant to
Jeff and tell it to behave like a casual
gremlin with the fire emoji. But what's
really awesome is that we can now start
building automations directly in the
chat. Like maybe I want to check and see
how my investment in Microsoft is doing.
We can ask Moltbot through Telegram and
it turns out it's not doing so well. But
it's not just going to pull this data
once. We now have an automation set up
in the background to keep track of this
stock. And when it moves significantly,
we'll get a message on Telegram. So now
there's no need in my life to go check
this stock manually. But unfortunately,
because I lost so much money in
Microsoft, I now need to get a real job.
So I might go ahead and install this
skill that will automatically generate
interview questions for software
engineers. But that's just the tip of
the iceberg of what's possible here.
It's an amazing tool you'll definitely
want to try out. Kind of like Tracer,
the sponsor of today's video. The Tracer
is an agent orchestration layer that
makes your coding agents a lot better at
building real world software. You start
by telling it what you want to build and
Tracer's new epic mode will ask you
follow-up questions to create a series
of specs and tickets. It just like real
engineering teams when they plan an
epic. Then it passes all of that context
to your favorite coding agent and tracks
the progress of each ticket in your
sidebar. The tracer uses a smart
orchestration system called Bart Simpson
that tracks what's actually happening
under the hood and corrects agents the
moment they drift. instead of just
blindly spamming more loops. If you want
to get more out of your coding agents in
2026, try out Tracer's new epic mode for
free with the link below. This has been
the Code Report. Thanks for watching and
I will see you in the next one.